I did want to ask you about Luke do you
have anything to say just about it
I know we miss to introduce myself I'm
well moving six feet apart at all times
both know the rules let me guess you're
the kind of guy that ignores the rules
cuz it makes you feel in control am i
right
you're not wrong you think that's cute
do you think it's cute congratulations
on the movie people are saying this is
the next Fault in Our Stars we need
multiple boxes of tissues to get through
it what does it mean to be a part of
movies that touch people so deeply hi
Haley
I think it's important I mean I think
the most the most important thing about
this movie is that it's bringing
awareness to cystic fibrosis which is a
rather underrepresented sees and I think
also it's it's really a movie about hope
it's no it's no new thing the the
star-crossed lover motif I mean it's
existed probably even before but then
solve it really and I think the fact
that we can utilize it and
take this narrative and find a funding
ability to bring an awareness the Cystic
Fibrosis through that star-crossed weber
narrative is something important for me
this guy behind me he had some nice
things to no pressure but he had some
nice things to say about you seriously I
mean he's the he's the reason I signed
on in the first place he's passion his
knowledge about cystic fibrosis was the
most reassuring thing about the process
it's easy within them within a movie
like this and within Hollywood in
general to sort of over romanticize
something that can be incendiary a
disease or an illness that real people
live within a real community of people
live with them you need to trust the
director you need to trust that we all
have the same mission statement I need
to be able to make sure that once you
wipe your hands clean of the set which
is really the only thing you can do as
an actor the post-production cycle is
going to honor what you did and I felt
all trust suggested well date night
tonight cool to come out this is a story
about young love everyone's obsessed
with your young love it's the 25th
anniversary of friends and I've sat down
with almost the entire past to talk
about it except Jen Aniston so far what
do you remember of your time on set
remember a lot I remember being
infatuated with Jennifer Aniston and I
also remember I remember as a kid being
quite intimidated because it was at the
point that I had stepped on it was a
really well oiled machine and it was a
bunch of older actors and I was the
youngest actor there and but I remember
everyone treating me so kindly I mean
truly and getting to meet a lot of cool
people behind the scenes
[Music]